you nervous for you you're just no
that's terrifying the only way our
society can survive is for each of you
to claim your rightful place
today you will take a test that will
help you discover who you truly are the
future belongs to those who know where
they belong
you ready your results were inconclusive
this was supposed to tell me what to do
we're supposed to trust the test didn't
work on you they call it divergent
you can't let them find out about you
they're always watching
you have to hide or they'd never expect
to find you
welcome to darkness
two stages of training first is physical
push your bodies to the breaking point
you're never gonna win like that it's
good to know keeps actually here
okay second is mental fish your worst
fears and conquer the night I made a
mistake choosing Thomas you'll find out
about you I know what you are it's been
a long time since I could trust anyone
I don't want to be just one thing I want
to be brave and selfless and intelligent
and honest and kind if you want to
survive
divergents threatening system it won't
be safe until they remove we have to
fight back
you